[Musique]
moi quand j'étais petit
ma même échauffés tellement les oreilles
avec ce proverbe qui dit
quand tu empruntes le schéma du je m'en
fous tu te retrouves au village du si je
savais
mais aujourd'hui moi je pourrais dire
quand tu emprunte le chemin de je m'en
fous tu peux te retrouves au village de
comment tu as fait
l'audace pour moi c'est la clé d'une vie
c'est affronter ses peurs
c'est se donner les moyens
et c'est ne pas écouter les gens je vais
vous raconter l'histoire d'un petit
garçon
ce petit garçon peut-être vous le voyez
filles
c'est moi on sentait déjà que j'allais
devenir styliste
l'histoire de ce petit garçon sait que
chaque fois su son chemin de l'école
il avait la tête toujours baissés en
train de chercher des buttes issus des
aiguilles
et les chiffons
et en classe quand les coups l'ennui les
sous sa table d'écolier en train de
bricoler ou coûtent ces
petites choses
mais au grand désarroi de cette
profession
trente cinq ans plus tard ouagadougou
burkina faso
à l'aube à homs il ya angélina jolie qui
arrive dans quatre jours est-ce que tu
pourras lui fait qu 4 up
angélina jolie qu'elle angelina jolie
l'actrice américaine vient chercher quoi
ici au burkina
et mais bazin dit tu pourras lui fait 4
up mais je veux que ce soit encore d'une
date puisque c'est ta signature
ok mais comme je trouve ces mesures
et son modèle mebazaa ne s'est pas le
créateur je te laisse le choix
tu pourras ou pas
ok pas de souci
mais je peux vous dit que angelina jolie
quand la porte est la rampe c'est comme
si on avait pris ces mesures
et elle a tellement aimé sa robe qu'elle
a porté pour la préhistoire est
présidentielle
et il faut dit que
déjà l'idée de ce panier venu à un
moment où le mont pays traversait une
crise sociopolitique et c'est en 2016 je
pense que vous vous en rappelez et moi
mon chiffre d'affaires et tbc à 50%
je me retrouve au marché de au grand
marché de ouagadougou et je tombe sur
une petite fille est en train de vendre
les pannes mais les pagnes m'attirait
tellement jeudi à et est un moment le
temps de lui parler sa maman est arrivée
et ça va me raconte l'histoire du
champagne qui pouvaient qui pouvait me
décourager mais loin de la fin ne m'a
pas découragé
au contraire ça m'a plus séduit et je
suis j'ai pris j'ai demandé à madame
cissé j'ai dit est ce que on peut
travailler ensemble parce que moi
j'aimerais retravailler les couleurs de
ces pannes et les mouches
mais quand je partais j'ai pris quelques
points et dans mon atelier quand
j'essayais de créer des chemises
quelques robes j'ai des clients qu'ils
arrivent et se met à rigoler mais base
est tombé aussi bas pour utiliser ce pas
là
mais moi cela ne découragea pas au
contraire parce que je savais où je
voulais aller
après je savais que le pagne était
d'origine de bobo dioulasso
ça ne m'a pas empêché de mêlée bien je
vous dis je pars boubou c'était ma
première fois que j'arrive à bobo
dioulasso au momen dans un quartier
qu'on appelle coco je rentre dans ce
quartier et je vois une centaine de
moment en train de travailler ce pagne
fait la tête hui à d'autres qui sont là
en train de sécher et en même temps leur
enfant qui coule de partout et pour moi
c'était comme c'est une usine je voyais
aux sorties de ce quartier j'ai dit moi
je vais changer le nom de ce pagne je
veux la paix le coq d'honda en hommage à
nos mamans de bobo dioulasso
et je reviens à ouagadougou j'organise
une conférence de presse
et je dis je change le nom de ce pagne
qui va s'appeler désormais aucun doute
dans l'entrée de coco pour ceux qui ne
savent pas en dessous là ça veut dire
l'entrée de coco
et quelques jours après je lance un
défilé privé avec le nouveau motif et
les nouvelles les nouvelles couleurs de
coordonner et après ce défilé
la presse nationale en a en a fait un
bond
et
je me suis pas arrêté là j'ai voulu
habiller les influences
les personnes fuyant pardon à commencer
par le couple présidentiel les ministres
les journalises les artistes nationaux
et internationaux
et
je ne suis pas arrêté là parce que pour
moi je dis j'ai envie de faire connaître
ce pagne et j'ai envie d'aider nos
moments
pour moi je veux que on appelle plus ce
pagne en oublie ce nom que je
connaissais qui étaient traités par
allart qui signifie à mon mari ne
travaille pas et déjà les femmes quand
on te dit je t'ai barral à travailler
ton mari même s'ils travaillent sont
favoris gâtés donc ça me fait dire que
donc petit à petit je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on l'appelle plus est et
barral à vous êtes d'accord avec moi
quand je regarde tout cette histoire
ça n'a pas commencé aujourd'hui j'ai
toujours été comme ça
aujourd'hui le candidat est labellisé et
aujourd'hui nos petit moment de cas
encore elle arrive à survivre à amener
leurs enfants à l'école à les scolariser
appuyé de départ celle des maisons ainsi
de suite mais quand mes voyages ne font
que mais ferme et béni mais je prends
parce que
pour moi déjà c'est
aider aujourd'hui c'est maman
a sorti de cette misère
et ça pour dire
ça n'a pas commencé pour moi c'est pas
aujourd'hui ça a commencé j'ai toujours
été comme ça dans ma vie
d'abord tout petit je demande à mes
parents que je vais faire la coach
quitté chose qui était difficile
entendre que mon père
mon père qui voulait que je fasse la
montagne passé pour lui dit que c'est le
métier de domme et la couture ce métier
de femme
mais il fallait convaincre mon papa ben
c'était compliqué il fallait passer par
ma mère et ma mais qui accepte de
m'envoyer chez son couturier de quartier
et
je reste trois mois après le coup tu
reviens dit à ma mère mais c'est vrai
ton fils il est il est très motivant 5
qui veut bien le métier est comme ça ma
mère décide mais n'a de m'acheter une
machine à coudre mais il machine vos
hanches et parce que je viens d'un
quartier et un bac hâtivement le dit
abidjan donc m'amène à un passé d'agent
mais elle achète une machine mais la
machine est tellement vide à cette heure
aux enchères dont moi j'ai les pieds en
rouge si vous remarquez c'était la seule
machine en rouge
mais alors cette machine j'en ai fait
faire des choses dans mon quartier c'est
nous on est dans les quartiers pauvres
mon ado fait les fêtes on adore les
uniformes
et qu'on fait les uniformes et amis du
caté geiler je les propose du coût de
leurs habits mais je coûte on habitue
n'a pas mais dit le modèle moi je crie
ça te plaît tu pas que ça te plait pas
tu n'as pas à parler
[Applaudissements]
et comme ça j'ai pour moi c'était un
entraînement donc mam était devenu comme
mannequin chaque dimanche à l'église
elle est toute pimpante qu'on lui
demande du coup ses habits elle nous a
dit que son fils parce que je suis en
train de m'en
donc
et je continue ou 10 à 13 ans aussi
à 13 ans je rêvais d'un arbre de noël
dans mon quartier pendant que je savais
même pas écrit quand j'écris à tous des
photos
mais comme josé qui à la mairie de mon
quartier et on me répond j'ai créé une
société de produits pour enfants on me
répond favorablement organise et la de
noël dans mon quartier et tous les
enfants étaient contents
pour dit j'ai toujours su sens
d'organiser l'organisation j'ai toujours
voulu organiser toujours voulu faire des
choses après
mon installation bookeen ans et ça a été
un gros choc pour mes parents
parce que pourquoi quand l'on parte à
l'école quand tu ne travailles pas bien
les conduire va t'emmener au bukina faso
entend au bukina faso quand ils
regardent la télé ce qu'on nous montre
les cases les violets 10 ha dont tu as
intérêt à travailler
mais non moi je dis je retourne cette
question à mes parents j'ai des bons
c'est moi je vais aller mais salle au
bout qu'il me dise n'est pas pas
beaucoup n'en faut rester ici
mais je suis venu au bouclage et prenez
ces personnes je sais que j'ai des
objets détente et août mais je
connaissais perso
j'arrive au bukina faso je prends ma
mère ans j'étais avec ma machine
je commence à kout moi c'était de bouche
à oreille est dans la même année c'est
en 2004
il y avait le sjao qui devait se fait je
n'ai pas assez de moyens pour mieux
prendre un stand dont je vois quelqu'un
qui tu veux bien se partagent les stands
et auto est comme ça pour moi c'était
pas de de vendre mais c'était plutôt de
métis et des contacts
et aussi à loos a très bien marché j'ai
eu deux beaux de deux de bonnes clientes
ou clients
et après un jury l'a sur les réseaux
sociaux et un conte coupe du jeune
créateur qui doit se passer du côté de
cameron
j'essaye de postuler mais sans savoir
que je serai retenu et on m'a envoyé une
lettre pour lui vous êtes retenus pour
participer au concours tout est pris en
charge votre billet d'avion votre tel
niveau tous les oies au hockey
donc je me retrouve au cameroun avec 15
pays
et aux sorties de ce concours je suis le
vainqueur et son copain de ce concours
chose que je ne m'attendais même pas
et je gagne le dé d'or
le dé d'or quand je viens à la personne
que georges ça ma mère parce que j'ai
voulu lui faire un bisou voulu offrir
est aujourd'hui gelée au fait ça parce
que pour moi voilà c'est grâce à elle
j'en suis
et au cameroun on me donne un frigo on
me donne un climatiseur et du même mois
ici au burkina faso je viens et salah
comme
donc je n'ai plus cher ça va vous mettre
à dos son parti mais l'essentiel
souvenait monde et d'or équivalent
et
vous dis que
j'ai toujours affronter les choses bien
que je ne connais pas je ne
je ne suis pas
magicien
je vais encore une anecdote ça c'est mon
épouse qui était un client comme tout le
monde elle est venue parce qu'elles
veulent une europe de une robe un des
mes défilés qu'elle avait vu mais moi
celle qui m'intéressait plus sinon la
robe
mais n avait rien à [ __ ] et je peux
vous dire que j'ai râlé des raies
pendant 4
mai le jouet m'a dit on va essayer je me
suis retrouvé à madagascar et on s'est
fiancé aujourd'hui en émail on a neuf
ans de mariage et deux petits enfants
et 1 et n était pas dans mon métier elle
elle était dans les ong au tout ça mais
aujourd'hui je peux vous dire que c'est
légal parce qu'on travaille ensemble
depuis deux ans et on s'entend
parfaitement bien
[Applaudissements]
pour moi
survivent
c'est être audacieux
c'est quoi ces rêves
c'est ne pas avoir peur de où on veut
aller et ne pas attendre ou écouter les
gens
parce que moi je crois en moi je crois
en la jeunesse africaine je pense qu'on
peut y arriver il suffit de se donner
les moyens et on va y aller je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]